hey there Matt yeah this was a very
narrow ruling but it was a loss for the
Obama administration at issue here is
the president's power to make recess
appointments that members of Congress
did not approve now in this case we're
talking about January 2012 when the
president appointed three members to the
National Labor Relations Board and
Senate Republicans said wait a minute
we weren't even technically on a recess
so the court here is deciding that the
president still does have the power to
make those recess appointments but
saying that in this case the
administration did not respect the the
will of the Congress that they were
actually weren't in recess it also puts
timeframes and limitations on what a
recess is so anything less than 10 days
isn't going to be considered a recess so
a narrow ruling there were some
questions whether or not this
presidential power was outdated it's
it's enumerated in the Constitution's
it's listed in the Constitution but that
was the time mat of the horse and buggy
era where there could be a vacancy that
needed to be filled at a moment's notice
and it would have been difficult for
people to communicate or get back on
time so there was some question that
this would have been completely
overturned again a narrow ruling but
definitely a hit to the Obama
administration